Raymond, thank you so much for joining
me today.
>> My pleasure.
>> So, before we get going, uh would you
share with listeners who you are and
what you do?
>> Um well, I'm this character that No, I'm
uh well, I'm primarily an author uh and
I've been a fellow at various think
tanks um focused on the Islamic question
from a historic doctrinal modern-day
point of view, terrorism and so forth.
I've been writ I've written multiple
books uh going all the way back to 2000
early 2000s and uh again exploring the
historical intersection between the west
and Islam which was often one based on
violence and conquest uh but I've also
written a lot about modern day terrorism
ISIS al-Qaeda one of my books was about
al-Qaeda and um other other another
phenomena I follow closely is the
persecution of Christians in the Islamic
world
>> and um so yeah primarily a writer also a
think tank fellow And uh increasingly
now I make I have a YouTube channel
which is uh I've been getting a lot of
good uh views and basically taking all
the stuff that I've been writing about
for the last 20 years and putting it in
a medium that people like more which is
video.
>> Yeah, absolutely. Yeah, I know. I'm I'm
trying to get caught up with YouTube
myself and it's it's not my forte. I
would rather uh just do audio all day.
But you know people you got to go where
they're at and that's that's where
they're at. So uh thank you for that
introduction. Um, I have uh started uh
your book, The Sword of the Scimitar,
and have to recommend that. I'll link
all of your books in show notes to
people. Um, they can find that and and
get learning because you obviously have
a ton of content there, and we could all
become a lot more knowledgeable about
what we're seeing happen in the world
today with some of that information. But
um you know I wanted to talk with you
because the the Islam question as you
mentioned has become more pertinent and
relevant than any of us realized I think
especially as we're starting to see some
of these election results come in and uh
you know last night with uh Zoran Mumani
winning the um mayor of New York City.
And so that's a big that's a big shift.
You know, as Americans, we're watching
one of our greatest cities seemingly
fall to uh just the the the
Islam, you know, advance of their of
their beliefs and of really uh seeking
to take power and take control of
whatever influence they can they can
gain for themselves. And so I know a lot
of conservatives today, a lot of
Christians specifically are um are
heavy-hearted, you know, about as they
they're watching what what appears to be
jihad kind of advancing across the
nation um through this kind of building
a parallel bu, you know, taking over uh
control and influence for themselves. Um
is there anything you can tell us about
like what we're seeing in terms of is
this actually jihad? because I I do see
people saying that, but I've also seen
some argue against it and say, "No,
that's that's not what you're seeing.
You're just seeing a fight for social
justice, and this is just Muslims really
wanting to have kind of equal
representation just like you would." So,
can you help us understand that?
>> Yeah. So, [clears throat] on the jihad
front, and I think you were telling me,
maybe you should uh you can elaborate.
You were telling me about someone on his
uh someone on Mandami's people actually
did use the word jihad, right?
>> She did. Yes. Yeah, let me let me tell
you what she said here. I've got um
let's see.
All right. Zoran Mamani's intern, Hadika
Arzu Malik, explains that electing him
is part of a holy war in jihad. I'll
play this here for you to listen to and
then I'll probably splice the clip into
our episode just so people can see it.
But here we go. Let me um it's on my
phone.
that none of this is in vain, that this
is all jihad, that this is all I and
that this is all counted for by Allah.
And so the conversation of doxing, the
conversation of getting arrested and
suspended,
I think it's time for Muslims to start
to say, "All right. All right. So what?
Do what you want. I'mma do I'mma do what
I got to do because that's it's it's
about time to do that." And I know
everybody has their own families and has
an education and everything.
>> It's just a question. We don't want to
get doxed and we don't want to get
suspended and we don't want to get
arrested.
>> How gangster are you? That's just my
question. How
>> Yeah, that's good enough.
>> Are you really And I know
[clears throat]
>> All right. Um I don't know what's her
name. Do you know her name or um
>> uh yeah her name is uh Hadika uh Malik
Arzu Malik.
>> And what's her position relative?
>> She's an intern with Zoran Mdani's uh
team.
>> All right. Okay.
So, ready? [clears throat]
>> Yeah.
>> All right. So, in regards to for example
what that intern female intern in the
hijab uh said about this is jihad. Uh
this is again a very very important
distinction that we have to actually
unpack because and I understand of
course her supporters so when she says
this is jihad everyone's saying ah see
she's a terrorist and her supporters are
of course going to argue the opposite.
No jihad means you're the greater and
lesser jihad etc etc and so let's get
into that. So historically uh
you know people Europeans translated
jihad as holy war because that is how it
historically manifested itself through
force because that was the only way for
Islam to make progress and uh achieve
its goal which is conquest and hegemony
was through force because we were living
in a day and age where people were not
stupid enough to be uh you know
undermined through whatever political
correctness like we are today. So the
only way to take over is you had to
actually go beat them and force them at
the tip of the sword. So that's why
historically historians including
Muslims when they say the word jihad the
connotation is holy war violence.
However, having said that it's
interesting to me that the apologetic
which is that no jihad means struggle
means to strive. Okay, that's what
Muslims say. It's interesting to me that
while that is true, it actually further
underscores the dangers of jihad because
yes, the word jihad that we translate or
orientalists translated as holy war
literally means to struggle and to
strive. However, it's understood in the
context. It's a religious idea. So, what
are you struggling and striving to do?
You're struggling and striving to
empower Islam over the entire world.
Okay, that is the ultimate Islamic
vision. Now, like I said, historically,
how do you do that? Well, through force,
because nobody's going to play your
game, and no one's going to just give
you what you want. Today, jihad is being
done not necessar force through
terrorist groups, but it's also being
done in what you're watching right now.
So, there are many classifications of
jihad amongst the or the scholars. Um,
there's the jihad of the pen, jihad of
the tongue, jihad of the money. Okay?
And what that means is jihad of lying,
jihad of propaganda, jihad of financing.
Okay. All of that is nonviolent. All of
that is in the current framework legal
and but all of it is still working to
the same exact goal that the jihadists
that we know, the more familiar types,
the terrorists are also working for.
Okay. So, this is I think the important
distinction and that's why when she says
that this is jihad and when they say,
"Oh, she doesn't mean military warfare,"
that does that still does not exonerate
what she's really saying.
>> Right? So ultimately all jihad leads to
the same end goal. Correct.
>> Correct. Yeah. Jihad, the end goal of
jihad, the vision of Islamic Sharia is
that Islam, Sharia law governs the
entire world and that's not the same as
forcing people to convert as long but
Islam must have hegemony over the world.
And then there's the you know the the
the Christians and the Jews can pay
tribute and be despised secondass the me
and pagans have to fight or die etc etc.
So there is that classification but the
ultimate goal is to conquer the world
through jihad which historically meant
force but now it's you have the soft
jihad struggling and striving in the
various ways that we mentioned including
through by getting into politics and uh
doing what they're doing.
So in the same way I kind of picture you
know like if during World War II uh
somebody was manning the the board the
and was an operator connecting the lines
between you know their their different
officials and let's say working for um
for Hitler. Okay. There's you've got
you've got somebody there manning the
phones and they're connecting lines
making things happen helping
communications go forward helping um you
know the plan and the missions get
carried out. Well, okay. They would have
been just as complicit in the the goal
of ultimate warfare against, you know,
their enemies as the man on the front
lines. They were not somehow you you you
could say, well, they're not at war.
They're not fighting for Hitler, but
it's like, well, not literally with a
gun. Okay. But but they're still they're
they're part of it. They're doing their
role. They're they're playing some
essential part and they are furthering
that end.
>> Yeah. And we have a lot of that you know
sticking again with just the Islamic
paradigm. Uh for example, our good
friend and ally Saudi Arabia is the
chief financeier of Islamic terrorist
organization is the chief financeier of
uh the of Islamic literature which it
disseminates all throughout especially
Europe in the mosques. Okay. And at the
same time it's our friend and our
western leaders go and dance and wave
swords with them and so forth. And yet
they are just as much complicit as the
guy the bad guys that you see. And
that's usually how it is. You know, at
the very tip of whatever you see the the
visible, you know, the terrorist, but
underneath it is a whole infrastructure
of support in including from people and
elements that we would call our allies.
Mhm. And so, uh, as we are seeing this
narrative go forth because it's it's
prevalent on social media, um, that it
is it is Islamophobic to to say any of
the things that that, you know, really
you say and that I talk about, uh, and
that we we really have an irrational
fear of of those who are Muslims and
they actually seek to live at peace with
us. uh you know what what would your
response be to those those types of
claims that you you are xenophobic and
you're Islamophobic and you're showing
your bigoted racism.
>> Well, I would say that um I am
Islamophobic literally and that's a
healthy thing to be because No, no,
because remember the word phobic phobia
means fear.
>> Okay, it doesn't mean hatred. The Greek
word for hatred is miss like a
misanthropist. Okay, hater of humanity.
But a phobe means to fear. But the point
of contention is the way it's used today
is it's an irrational fear. It's not an
irrational fear because if you're
familiar with history like I am, if
you're familiar with Islamic doctrine,
there is an unwavering continuity that
goes on decade after decade, century
after century for well over a millennium
of Muslims engaging in violence against
non-Muslims and saying it is part of
their religion. Okay. So, how can I So,
for me to be afraid of Islam, I think
that's the natural response of anyone.
Um, but of course, what they're trying
to imply, it's irrational. There's
nothing irrational about an unwavering
line of continuity of hostility and
hatred that starts with Islam that is
copulously documented both in Islamic
sources and in non including Christian
sources and that played out century
after century and saw so much conquest
so much blood said so much violence that
Hindus alone apparently something like
80 million were killed in the name of
jihad over five centuries okay that's
just one group of people and the same
thing happened to the Christian people
forget the western world, the Christian
world, the vast majority of it was
actually conquered by Muslims and that
the countries that we today nonchalantly
think of as Islamic were actually the
heart of the Christian world. And that
would include Syria and Egypt and all of
North Africa. Okay, if you went in the
7th century, most of Christianity was
deeply implanted in that area more than
in Europe. Okay, and all of that got
conquered. Um, so and Europe got
assaulted for centuries. Spain was
conquered. the Balkans. Um, you know,
you had slave raids going as far as
Iceland also in the name of jihad.
America's first war 12 centuries after
the birth of Islam again was in the name
of jihad and Christian American sailors
were being um, you know, enslaved and
tortured and killed. And when when
Jefferson met in Adams, they met with
the Barbrey ambassador, he told them our
religion, our book, our prophet, our
Allah says you're the enemy and we have
to do this to you. And then you fast
forward till today and you have Muslims
still saying this sort of thing. So in
what don't you you'd have to be out of
your mind not to f not to be a
non-Muslim and not to have some fear uh
of Islam. Okay. So that that's my
response that Islamophobia that word
itself exists out of absolute and pure
ignorance of reality.
>> Right. Right. And that's just
unfortunately what we see is that that
you know people don't understand and
they don't have any knowledge actually
of what Islam teaches and what they
believe. So kind of dialing a little bit
deeper because we started with a current
events question. What are the core
drivers of the Islamic religion? And and
I I want to specify too like I would
love for you to clarify for us. Uh, one
of the one of the things we're coming up
against in in the United States is the
fact that our own constitution baked
into it obviously has freedom of
religion. And so it is it is almost
embedded in our country to weaken our
own um our own nation when we import
people with with a religion that
fundamentally denies our values and goes
against our beliefs which our founding
fathers understood because they said
that our constitution would not be able
to govern a a people that were not moral
and religious and it was only meant to
do that. And so I would love for you to
kind of unpack a little bit of that that
idea that it it's more than just a
religion and that it actually bleeds
into the socopolitical realm as well and
and what the you know and and how that
differentiates it from potentially other
other religions,
>> right? Well, [clears throat] the whole
freedom of religion thing that the
founders had in mind was entirely based
on Christianity. They didn't expect uh
Hindus and Muslims and Buddhists and
anyone else to be coming. It was the
idea that, you know, well, Christians
had been they're broken up into sex and
they're fighting and you have the
Protestants among themselves are
fighting and the Catholics and whatnot.
So, it was freedom of religion within
Christianity and Christianity of itself
when it comes to conquering and the
infidel is innocuous regardless of which
sect uh you follow. So, I think that was
the idea. Don't mind the cat. All right.
uh and um but now when you come to Islam
and you know your original question is
so well the doctrines the Islam is
inherently uh what you would call
tribalistic and I don't mean tribalistic
by blood it what Muhammad as I always
say his genius is that he took the
tribal mores of 7th century Arabia that
he was born in and uh he rearticulated
it through a theological paradigm which
[clears throat] made it very powerful
and made it live on because now it's not
just tribalism which is a historical
phenomena that could sort of go away on
its own, you know, through pro through
progress and the advancement of time and
interaction of different cultures. It
becomes what God wants. So, what I mean
by this is tribalism is uh we're one
group and you're another group and we
hate, kill, and plunder you and enslave
you because you're not part of our
tribe. I mean, that that that was across
the board. That's all throughout
history, including in Europe when you go
back to that tribalistic day, those
days. Um, so Muhammad said, "Okay, the
new tribe is the ummah, the Muslims.
We're one people and the non-Muslims,
they're the opposite tribe. They're the
evil ones, the e the infidels,
basically." Okay? And uh so
[clears throat]
in fact, in the Quran, it basically says
if your father, your mother, your
children, all your relatives are not
Muslims, they're the enemy. And it also
says that you have to hate the
non-Muslim in principle. And I've, you
know, a lot of the Islamic clerics, I've
recorded some, translated them basically
saying, "Yeah, you can marry a
non-Muslim, but you have to hate her.
You can enjoy her whatever way, but you
have to hate and show her that you hate
her because it's an Islamic doctrine."
Okay. So, this this tribalistic
worldview, which is us Muslims versus
them, the infidels, just completely
permeates the religion. And that's what
led to what I was referring to, the
historical massive onslaught against the
West and the rest, not just the West,
all non-Muslims. Um, and so that
mentality has always lived on. It used
to be it it was to the point that if you
had, if you were in Europe and you're a
Christian king and you want to send a
emissary to speak to the Khalif or
something, he had to get a special
permit because otherwise he'd get killed
once he entered Islamic lands because
that's what Muslims will do to the ker.
You immediately kill or enslave him.
That's the that's what he exists for.
Okay. So now that mentality, it's still
there. It's part of the religion. It's
baked in. And now uh so I wonder did the
founders [laughter] have that kind of
religion in mind when they said freedom
of religion? Because what kind of
citizens does that make? And this is
precisely why when you look at in Europe
where you have large numbers of Muslims,
they don't assimilate. They live in
enclaves. It's it's like a ghetto. They
don't they don't they hate their host
nation country, okay? Because they don't
they're there. They're there to benefit
and take over or whatever, but they're
not there to be one with you. They're
not there because they're civic-minded.
They're ultimately still seeing things
through a tribal lens. You are the enemy
by by default. Okay? And um so that's
that is the conundrum. You know, in as
much as America identifies freedom of
religion as all religion, not what it
originally meant, which was the
Christian religion and its many guises
and uh you know, denominations and
splits. As long as it it applies to all,
well, you're going to have this sort of
dual loyalty thing with Muslims. Uh
because again, the doctrine I'm telling
you about uh about hating, it's actually
it's a two-part doctrine. It's called in
Arabic al
means loyalty to fellow Muslims to Islam
and Baret means enmity and hatred for
the non-Muslim, the infidel. Okay? So
that's the the that's tribalism, right?
Perfect tribalism. And so if you get
that mentality and you say, "Hey, I'm
going to make it and bring it into my
country and let's of course you're going
to have chaos." And that's what you're
seeing in these European nations,
especially, you know, the UK,
um, Sweden, France. It's just a
non-stop. uh you have this element
that's agitating that doesn't want to
assimilate that's not there to be one
with you they don't see themselves as
French they don't see themselves as
British they don't see themselves as
Swedish they are Muslims okay and uh so
yeah that's that is at core the issue
you have a religion that is not about
assimilating that is black and white
that's us versus them and then you have
that kind of people being brought in and
everyone's acting like oh yeah they
think just like us and they see the
world just like we do.
>> So when someone says, and I'll give you
an example of where this came up, but
someone says, "Hey, you know, I I think
that this this man, he's a Muslim, but I
think he really has assimilated um
locally. There was an election for a
city near me where the uh there was a
Democrat that ran and a Muslim who ran
as sort of the conservative party like
he represented more of the conservative
ideas like he was against low-income
housing developments near me. Um and so
I had friends being like, "Hey, are you
going to vote for this guy who's known
to be a Muslim, but he's got more
conservative principles he's running on
compared to the Democrat?" And I was
like, "Absolutely not." Like, I'm not I
under no circumstances would I ever vote
for a Muslim. I don't care which what
principles you know he says he's running
on but this idea was was pushed to me
that you know I well I think he's
assimilated um although he he definitely
was still very clearly Muslim. Is that
possible? Is it possible that a Muslim
assimilates or if they're being a good
Muslim is that really them just being
deceptive?
>> It well yeah it really goes on to what
kind of Muslim they are. If they are a
cultural Muslim like a lot of them are
who don't know much about the religion
or don't care. are secular-minded, yeah,
they can't assimilate. And a lot of that
has to do with um it also has to do with
numbers. So, you know, in America, it's
easier, I think, for Muslims to
assimilate because there's less Muslims.
And so, you know, if you put them if you
put a Muslim or anyone who's non-western
and amongst a lot of Westerners and not
many of their kind, then they are prone
to assimilate. But if you put them like
in Europe where it's just heavily
concentrated and they don't they never
leave their neighborhoods, they're
always around fellow Muslims. they don't
talk to uh the natives of Europe then
yeah assimilation is absolutely
impossible at that point but also yes
there's the question of you know what is
the driving what what is the what is
that person's Islam to them
>> okay I do believe there are I don't call
them moderate Muslims what I call them
like I said cultural or nominal Muslims
yeah you have that in every religion
right you have that with Christians who
are called Christian but they're not um
so that does exist that's a reality
But one of the other issues is there is
in fact a whole teaching and a whole
doctrine that tells Muslims you can lie
and you can't pretend and you can't
conceal your truth. So there you have
another category who do act moderate,
who do act indifferent about religion
but who actually are also engaged in
jihad. Okay, the the struggle um and
they're enga but they're also doing it
uh through clandestinely and
deceptively. So because that is
absolutely an Islamic teaching and that
has also manifested itself historically
very frequently. So you know you yeah
you have three groups. You have the
radicals who won't assimilate as they
call them. You have the nominal who can
and then you have the guys in the middle
who are radical but are acting like
they're not.
>> Okay. And so a lot of people have talked
about and there's been lots of
speculation on whether Zoran Mdani of
you know now the New York uh mayor
whether he is engaged in tea or not. Uh
and I don't know if you you have an
opinion on that or not but he ran as a
socialist and he ran on kind of
socialist principles of hey we're going
to you know provide a bunch of free
housing for you guys. We're going to
make New York City a better place. we
want to basically just hand out, you
know, free stuff left and right. And of
course, the uneducated, you know, um,
foreigner in New York City has obviously
voted for that. They want that. Um, but
I think there's a lot of speculation
about, well, is he actually a socialist
or a communist or is he just really kind
of using whatever political means he can
to get people to vote him into power?
Now, as far as the, you know, the whole
issue of the leftist and he's a
socialist and all that, you know, this
goes way back. A lot of Muslims actually
uh know how to tap into this sort of
leftist uh atmosphere and exploit it for
themselves. I remember way way back uh
when I was translating al-Qaeda writings
that they would actually send
communicates to the disaffected blacks
of America because of racism and how
they're going to they want to help you
and because of what the white man did to
you and we want to bring equality and
freedom. So yeah, that's that's
definitely an old tactic that is a
jihad, a soft jihad um to try to win
over the leftists. And you know, in
general, this sort of leftist Islam
alliance has been around for a long
time. And it's usually it's a one-way
street where you have uh foolish
leftists empower Muslims and then once
the Muslims are in power, they're done
with the leftists. Okay? And there was
just a I saw a video just recently in
the UK of these masked hundreds of
Muslim men dressed in black and masked
looking like intentionally so ISIS
marching I think in London. And uh
there's also some dumb leftist native
Brits there on their side cuz I guess it
was something about they're protesting
the anti-immigrant other side. And the
Muslims start chanting Allah Akbar,
which of course is uh is is Islam's
distinct Islam's ancient war cry. So one
of the dumb leftists is like, "No, bro.
We're on the same side." And the Muslim
one Muslim guy says, "No, we're not."
Okay? And you know, and there it is.
That's the truth. Okay? That's the
absolute best way to see it. Um and
there's the other there's the other
example I think it was in Ham Tram
Tramik in Michigan um which uh you know
the leftist helped it's it has a very
large Muslim population and now they
have a I think the city council is
majority Muslim and uh once they became
majority Muslim they canled uh you know
homosexual stuff pride uh that's that
sort of thing and the left was so upset
about it and you know oh we helped you
and how could you do that so that is the
modus operende between the Islam and the
left. Islam rides the left uh because
they're stupid and once it gets in
power, it's basically done with them and
uh moves on to bigger and better things.
Another question, another uh, you know,
error I guess I've seen floating around
is that this idea of um, the way that
Muslims are advancing their religion
through this struggle, through this
fight or war is not unlike Christianity
because, you know, scripture speaks
about a spiritual war in Ephesians 6.
And so, why is that any different? you
know, and I literally saw this comment
today. Um, someone saying this is really
parallel to Jesus and the teachings of
Jesus. So, I don't know what you guys
are freaking out about. Uh, on the one
hand, I'd agree that actually most
Christians don't appreciate the uh the
the teachings of Christianity that are
actually proactive and, you know, almost
militant, not necessarily through
violence, but very aggressive and
assertive, which include, of course,
fighting spiritual forces and all that.
So, I do agree with that. But uh
Christianity as far as I know doesn't
have a mandate to conquer the world and
by the sword. Okay? So that's the
difference. Uh it's one thing a
missionary is a missionary. He's going
to another country preaching Christ and
helping people. A jihadist is a
jihadist. He enters a country and kills
people and says you have to accept my
religion or at least be subject to it.
So that's worlds apart. That's like I
don't I don't even begin to see that
argument at all.
>> Right. Yeah. So, let's talk about the
persecution of Christians that's
happening in in Islamic countries. This
another headline obviously in Nigeria.
You know, we've got uh genocide taking
place and um there are there are some
large influential voices in in the
United States who are actually seeking
to really discredit that narrative and
are saying, well, Muslims who are not
radicals are being killed, too. It's not
just Christians. This is not a targeted
genocide of Christians. This is not
Christian persecution. and I've seen
that narrative um being pushed. What is
your commentary or analysis of that?
>> I've been following this since maybe
2009 when it first started and I've been
writing every month about it. So, I know
a fair bit about what's happening in
Nigeria and the claim that Christians
are not being targeted is absolutely
false and it's a lie and I get that and
that's easily demonstrable by looking at
what Christians say. Okay, so first of
all, they're constantly being targeted.
They're being killed by men dressed in
black screaming Allah Akbar. Why are you
screaming about your god, why are you
screaming the jihadist war cry uh if
this isn't about religion?
>> In fact, I recall a nun saying exactly
that. She's like, she said a Nigerian
nun. said it's very hard to make us
believe this isn't about religion when
when these guys attack us they make it
about religion and they burn churches
and they you know and they you know so
it started off you had a group called
Boo Haram in northern Nigeria which is
Muslim majority and they definitely
targeted and killed Christians. I mean
the amount of churches that have been
bombed or burned usually packed with
Christians okay in Nigeria is
ridiculous. I mean, probably hundreds
over the years, right? And uh and it's
and it and they target them on their
most packed holidays, Easter, you know,
Christmas, uh New Year's and things of
that sort. So, uh it's certainly a jihad
the guys who are doing this. So, the
here's what they're trying to say. Now,
since Boo Haram, there's another group
which are herdsmen. They're called the
fani herdsmen, okay? And they're what
they do is they attack cities and
settlements and they plunder and burn
and kill and destroy and rape and
enslave, okay, and take hostages. And it
just so happens that almost all the ones
that they attack have are Christian
villages or Christian majority. The
issue though is nonradical nominal
Muslims. Remember I was telling you
about those? A lot of them live side by
side with the Christians and these and
the m the Muslim radicals kill them.
Okay? And they act and that is
legitimate in the context of jihad
because oh you're a sympathizer with the
infidel. Well too bad you die. They have
whole doctrines justifying that. Okay.
Um so but the media is trying to use
that as oh see it has nothing to do with
religion because once in a while a
Muslim also dies. Okay. But it's not.
It's very clear if you and I you know I
interviewed a bishop recently. So we the
point is when you talk to the people who
are there, it is unequivocally a jihad
of terrorism against Christians. They
all say that and it's so it's very
hypocritical for some western element or
western talking head to come tell me no.
And I'll give you a perfect example of
how they do this. One of the worst I was
telling you about the bombing of
churches. One of the worst happened
maybe three years ago and again it was
something like it was on a holy day and
it was packed and I don't know 50
Christians were blown up and uh all of a
sudden because people pointed out what
I'm pointing out uh it the Irish
president made some statement and he was
horrified saying how dare you the fani
are innocent this is and and they're the
innocent ones and they're the victims
because of climate change. So now the
argument is because of climate change
the fani are leaving their former
pastoral spots and uh encroaching on the
settlements of farmers who often who
almost all happen to be Christian and
the fani all happen to be Muslim. Okay.
So be that as it may, it still doesn't
change the fact that they see it as a
justification to kill and attack the
Christians because they're the infidel
and it's their right to take their land
anyway because they're the infidel. So
my point is I have no problem trying to
give this some depth and say it's not
just Muslims killing Christians and that
there are other factors. However, the
fact that the Christians are being
targeted is because they're seen as the
most expendable. They are again remember
what I said about tribalism. They are
the de facto enemy. So why would we go
and start killing Muslim majority
villages when we got these infidels? and
they articulate it they themselves
through religious slogans, jihadist
slogans etc. So it it is absolutely
ultimately being driven by the jihadist
imperative to persecute, kill, attack,
enslave, blunder Christians.
>> Yeah. And so as we, you know, are
watching, you you mentioned obviously
Europe has just been completely overrun
by Muslims and we're seeing uh obviously
we've seen a huge increase here in the
US and thankfully there's some, you
know, hopefully some movement as we're
deporting people who are here illegally.
Uh but there's still a a big concern for
um just the the the importation of this
religion, this belief, this uh really
aim to kind of convert America into a
Muslim nation. I mean, is it it doesn't
sound to me like you would say it is
fear-mongering to say that that is the
ultimate end?
>> Oh, no. That's not it. It Here's the
thing. The way I see it, it's not the it
is the ultimate end. But and now we
really have to get honest and say this
isn't really the Muslims fault, this is
the West's fault.
>> Because the Muslims on the one hand,
yeah, they want to spread their
religion. It's like the missionary
impulse even though they're not doing it
through peaceful or or necessarily um
overt means. They're doing it, you know,
in these other problematic ways, but
they just want to see the religion
spread and they want to see the infidels
come under the fold of Islam. Okay, I
get it. Um it's the problem is that the
West is so easily susceptible to this.
Like I told you, Historically the west
Europe uh the only way Islam is going to
enter is through through at the tip of
the sword. Okay? Nobody's going to say
oh we believe oh have here let me make a
prayer place for you in my church or in
you know in the St. Peter Vatican
library or whatever the case is okay
because you worship a false god who
actually is against my beliefs etc.
Everyone got that. So a lot of the
problems today, if we were going to be
interested, if we're going to be honest
and introspective, it's the West fault
for actually completely undermining its
own uh spiritual and moral foundation
that there's nothing left that something
like Islam once an abomination from a
Christian western point of view is seen
as an alternative to fill the void.
>> Yeah. And so what would you say to the
Christian who uh has been, you know, it
what would I guess your your admonition
be to them that that they have bought
the lie of progressivism and of kind of
woke woke theology that, you know, like
you said, they're just like us. They
just want to worship in their own way
and we need to give them the space and
respect their right. And how dare you?
You profess to be a Christian and what
do you want to, you know, have Christian
nationalism? Like I mean that's that's
the majority of I I feel like even our
pastors really in the west would
probably kind of fall under that line of
thinking and and find it um unthinkable
that a Christian would not want to grant
the freedom of religion and and allow
privilege to another religion out of
respect and love of God. Like they would
catch it in that. I mean I see that all
the time.
>> Yeah, I do too. And none of those people
are actually Christians. Of course,
because if you're a Christian and you
believe in the Christian world view, you
want Muslims to become Christian. Like I
said, this is why I don't blame Muslims
for wanting non-Muslims to become
Muslim. This is normal. This is healthy.
This is a reflection of you actually
believe in your faith. Okay? You want to
see it spread. So for a Christian to
tell me, "Oh, I want to make sure that
they can worship their God." Well, I
guess you don't believe in what
Christianity teaches. I guess you don't
believe in heaven and hell. I guess you
don't believe in saving souls. You're
just a I don't know a feel-good leftist
with the garb of Christianity. And that
is the overwhelming uh majority I think
of Christianity today in the West. So I
get that. Um but they are they just and
they and that exactly is the problem
that I was referring to. Uh if you're a
Christian and you feel like you want to
accomp I'm not saying you should attack
Muslims or tell them or try to prevent
them from their worship, but going out
of your way to um you know appease and
praise their world view that's an
abnigation of your own and you don't get
it because you're an idiot. No, you I
mean that kind of person.
>> You don't understand that you just told
the Muslim that my I have no faith in my
religion so by all means uh let me help
you uh uh uh you know worship in yours.
So that that right there is the rot uh
that there is the reflection that there
is no Christianity or very very little
in the west and that is precisely why
Islam which is inherently weak and
unappealing is able to fill the void
because there is that big void.
>> Well, you sound like you are saying that
Christianity should be privileged among
above other religions in in the United
States. Do you believe in Christian
nationalism?
Um, well, I don't even know what that
means, but No, no,
>> I don't even know. [snorts]
>> No, because from what I do, what it
means, I I don't think it's bad. In
other words, I think I think it gets
attacked and uh Yeah.
>> Right. Right. I mean, that's kind of my
point is like if you're not going to
have Christian nationalism, you'll have
Muslim nationalism. You'll have
>> you you will. And so I I think
historically I think what we've seen I
mean I know the term has a lot of
different definitions but that being
that that Christianity should be
privileged in a Christian nation
is seen as like this boogeyman right
it's seen as like how dare you I mean
why
>> the religion that
>> the religion of every single
civilization other than Christianity is
privileged in those civilizations I mean
obviously Islam but even uh India the
Hindus the Sinaic civilization Buddhism,
of course, they're privileged. And that
makes sense. It's their lands. Okay? You
have to assimilate. You have to uh you
know live within that. But of course,
again, in Christian lands, they've been
fooled into thinking, "Oh, yeah. So, you
have to actually u Christianity also has
to be watered down to accommodate
everyone else." Okay. Well, I mean, look
at it any way you want, but like I just
said, it's also a reflection of your of
your own lack of faith because um it
just shows that you don't you want
people if you believe Christianity is a
truth, you should want to spread it.
Okay? And and if you and if it's not
Christianity, it's error. If it's if
it's not if Christianity is true, Islam
is an error. So why are you enabling and
advocating for Muslims to stay in the
religion? That again like I said just
shows the the contradiction the very
visible contradiction in that kind of
mentality and that's why it's it's
that's why Christianity is basically
falling apart in the west.
>> So I want to ask why did you say Islam
is weak and unappealing? I mean I know
why I think it's unappealing but why
what makes it weak? because I think it
comes across to those especially, you
know, watered down Christians who just
kind of have a milktoast, you know,
version of quote unquote Christianity as
seeming to be a very authoritative and
strong um you know advancing aggressive
religion. So why do you say that it's
weak? By weak, what I mean is, yeah,
Islam is patriarchal, masculine, and all
that sort of thing, but it's militarily,
economically weak as on the world stage.
In other words, if uh if the west
tomorrow turned into a crusader state,
the way the crusaders thought uh in
let's say the 12th century, Islam would
be done. Okay? If that old war came
about. So it is inherently weak, but
it's d it's but if you bring it in. So
my point is historically uh you know
Muslims conquered the regions that I
told you and they bombarded Europe and
tried to conquer Europe by force okay
and the Christians fought back etc etc.
Um now the problems that we're seeing
the violence and the terrorism and the
some random Muslim goes stabbing people
okay which is like constantly in Europe
that is being that is not because they
invaded and are by force that is being
enabled by western elements who bring
them in. Okay. So the so the Islam
problem can be solved like that. Okay?
If in any of these sovereign western
nations, you look at a country like
Hungary and it says, "Well, we don't
want Muslims." So guess what? You can
walk in the streets at night and you're
not going to get raped and you're not
going to get mugged. Okay? And it's a
nice city still, right? And uh how did
they do that? Wow. How miraculous was
that? Well, they just said no to Islam.
Okay? As as one example. uh whereas
these powerful countries like in the UK
and France, they're they're like a war
zones now because you allowed it. So
that's what I mean by it's weak. And by
being unappealing,
>> Islam has never been appealing. Most of
the people who converted to it, it was
at the tip of the sword or more
frequently because okay, I don't want to
be a subject to them me. I want to
actually be, you know, engage in social
mobility and move up. So they became
Muslim. But the religion itself is not
really appealing. Um and uh but the
point is the alternative is even less
appealing. The void. Okay. What is the
western man or woman? What are they
supposed to live for? Materialism,
hedonism, you know, just uh nothing
really. So something as intrinsically
unappealing as Islam is actually
arguably more appealing than that. And
that's what I mean. there's a void that
Islam which is weak and unappealing is
actually filling because we are not
allowed to have the alternative.
>> And so what can the Christian do who
agrees with everything you're saying,
who sees the problem for what it is and
yet is, you know, endlessly frustrated
by the lack of political will of our
politicians to actually fight for us as
citizens. What can we do?
>> Well, that's the thing. you know, the
the system inherently seems to be flawed
because what we should be able to do is
vote in people who sound like us, right?
>> But uh more often than not, whoever
sounds like us, once they get voted in,
then they stop doing what they said they
do. Um so that's what I mean by the
system is kind of inherently flawed in
the sense. Uh what are you going to do?
I don't it just seems like to me that,
you know, in the current paradigm, the
best we ever see is always one step
forward and two steps back. one step
forward, two steps back, which is a
constant decline overall over time if
you look if you step back and look at
it. Um I don't know. I just know that uh
you know when I know you're not supposed
to say this, but when people feel that
some injustice is happening, they've
often turned to force. I mean, uh, the
American founders that were supposed to
heroise, did they continuously stay in
this toxic relationship with the Britain
and just keep saying, "Oh, we're going
to find a voice for us." Well, no. They
said no. And they just said they broke
off uh force. And that's considered a
good thing because believe it or not, uh
sometimes if you just try to do it
through uh diplomacy, which is a good
thing. I'm not arguing that. uh the
other side can just keep playing along,
you know, just taking you for a fool and
it goes on decade after decade while
they consolidate more and more power and
you become a minority and a weak and a
weak person in your own country. Uh
because that's what the game is designed
for. So I wonder when people say enough
is enough, this current paradigm is
broken and we need to take matters into
our own hands.
>> Do you have I mean you have obviously a
ton of knowledge of history. You've seen
how this has played out over thousands
of years because this is what you write
about. This is your, you know, entire
professional career. Do you have any
hope for the West at this point? Like
what is your kind of professional
opinion and analysis of do you how do
you think this is going to play out?
Like what do you actually think is going
to happen next?
>> I think it's going to it's going to keep
getting worse before it can possibly get
better because people are just so uh
their brains are just so adultled right
now. I mean to me what we call the left
and the right I don't even use those
paradigms because they don't make any
sense to me. What I see is okay the the
ultraright that's normal people uh like
and I know this because if you look at
outside the west and you go to another
country what we call ultra rightight
which is dangerous okay whatever it is
and you can define it I don't know
nationalism pride in your culture and
your history and your race all that that
is everyone outside the west that's the
default and the and the governments are
the ones who actually promote that more
than anyone okay so to me ultraright is
a normal healthy
And then in as much as you start veering
leftwards uh you know my paradigm is
when you get when you get to the center
that's nihilism that's just uh I don't I
don't believe in anything goes okay and
then when you start moving past that now
something has to fill the nihilism which
I call insanity which is why the further
further left you go you're just a crazy
person okay and uh so that's the the
real situation that we're dealing with
there's a war on normality and there's a
promotion of making you m an insane
person uh because it's easy to control
you and get you to do what you you know
what they want you to do. So that
paradigm needs to be broken and people
need to see the truth of what's really
going on. Um and the ultraright is not a
bad thing. That's actually just being a
normal person, the way people have been
historically and the way they are today
outside of the West. It's curious why is
it only the west that's bombarded with
this message that you have to suppress
your religion, you have to suppress your
culture. You have to give your land, you
know, to all these non western people.
Who else does that? Nobody does it. And
yet, if you look at the world, the vast
majority of the world is non-white. I
think whites, depending on what you look
at, is anywhere between five and 9%.
Okay? So why is that small minority the
one that has to keep appeasing the
masses and give up its land, its
cultural, its heritage? Obviously, this
is all by design. So people need to wake
up and understand what's going on and
then do something about it.
>> Yeah. Last question. I want to know what
what gave you a personal interest in
this area? Like what what drives you and
and why are you passionate about it?
What's your what's your story with how
you got into being so um you know
spending all of your waking hours really
writing and researching and and helping
educate people about uh the history of
this of this battle and this religion?
>> Well, I a long long time ago I just
decided, you know, the secret to
everything is in history and that so
much of what we're told are lies and a
lot of them are what I call fake
history. So much of what we uh so much
of the narratives that we believe in
today are built on fake histories which
are much more dangerous than fake news
which people are familiar with because
the latter fake news are ephemeral. You
know they make their argument they make
their issue and then they go away maybe
they get corrected or caught. But fake
history creates overarching narratives
whereby whereby modern arguments are
articulated. Okay. So, for example, if
you believe in the the idea that, you
know, whites and Europeans are somehow
the only slavers in history and they've
enslaved more people than anyone, well,
you're going to conclude whites are
intrinsically evil, whites are bad,
you're going to hate whites, and if
you're black, you might get up and just
stab a white person for the heck of it
because that happens a lot. All right?
And uh, you know, and there's academic
support for this. There's a Britney
Cooper is a a black Rutgers professor
who literally says what I just said,
that white people are inherently evil.
Okay? But if you understand true history
and understand that yes, white people
did engage in slavery, but so did
everyone else [laughter]
and at least white people are the ones
who abolished it globally. Okay, then
you have a better understanding. So
anyway, that's why I've always been very
much intrigued and interested in history
because I believe that's where you can
get to the truth of things. Um, and
there's a lot of deception right now
going on. Uh, and it's not just Islam. I
mean, Islam is my sort of my job. That's
what I write about. But I, you know, I
would encourage people to delve into
history in general, uh, because, and,
and I don't mean go get what's being
sold in Barnes & Noble because that is
the fake history and it's not that easy
that, you know, you have to understand
the primary sources in various languages
and so forth. So, I I get why it's a
problem. But anyway, that's why I'm
interested in history.
>> I think that's, yeah, well said. Uh that
get back gets back to the comment that I
shared with you at the beginning of the
conversation around the the girl on
social media who said to me, "I don't um
I don't think that we should make the
leap to say that Zoran Mani's intern is
talking about any sort of holy war.
She's doing a lesser jihad, which is
really just fighting for social
justice." And then I said, "Well, this
shows that you're you're very ignorant
and you really have no knowledge of
history." and she said, "Well, actually,
I have a history degree and a world
religions degree to so, you know,
there's that." And I was like, "You just
proved my point."
>> Well, that's the irony. And and it and
it proves a very good point, which is
actually it's the people who do have
degrees in history all the way up to a
PhD that end up being the worst ones
because they're indoctrinated in lies.
You know, the average person who doesn't
have a degree in history may
instinctively understand what I'm
talking about at least. But the person
who does have a degree has been
bombarded and embied all the lies of
propaganda that now they respond with
great confidence. I know I have a degree
in history and yet what they're saying
is is usually the antithesis of reality.
>> Yeah, exactly, man. Well, thank you so
much for your time. Where can people um
follow your work and and connect find
you online?
>> Uh my website's a good one-stop place.
Raymond.com. R A Y M O N D I B R A H I
M. It has a lot my articles and books
and links and so forth and also my
YouTube channel, the Holy War channel,
which also I think is under my name. All
right, we'll point people there. Thank
you again for your time today.
>> Thanks for having me.